burning anger in uganda's capital
kampala
as word spread of the arrest of bobby
wine
who these protesters want as president
[Applause]
that message was clear as they defaced
images of long-time leader yawari
museveni
[Applause]
security forces responded by firing tear
gas and arresting dozens of
demonstrators
[Applause]
but it's this moment that brought them
onto the streets
about a hundred kilometers away the pop
singer turned politician bobby wine
was campaigning in lucca when he was
arrested
and bundled into a police van security
forces cited repeated violations of
covet 19 restrictions
following his arrest bobby wein tweeted
that resistance
is a duty analysts say he's gaining
popularity among
young people who are hoping he will
bring change to a country
ruled by president museveni for three
and a half
decades museveni's party insists the
president
is still popular i think we have to look
at the at the end of the day the
demographic
shifts are not in favor of president
museveni who has been in power for
35 years personally i've never seen any
other president
so it's very important to know that
people are looking for a change
wine has been in politics since 2017
when he won a seat in the national
assembly
the presidential hopeful has been
arrested many times soon
this is what security forces did to his
car after he submitted nomination papers
to run for president
wine says he's been repeatedly beaten
and tortured
while police continue to crack down on
his supporters
people have a right to demonstrate
demonstrate peacefully
any excessive use of force by security
forces anywhere
is of concern to us
and it is important that there is a
space provided for people to express
themselves
whether in demonstration or through a
democratic process
uganda has never witnessed a peaceful
transfer of power since independence in
1962.
with the presidential election set to
take place in january
tensions are high with wine regarded as
museveni's strongest challenger
during his decades in power lawyer about
him and the al jazeera